who here has seen the movie The Matrix
all right now keep your hands up if
after you saw The Matrix you pretended
that you were neo okay I think there's
some Liars in this audience too cuz I
know you were going home and practicing
those kung-fu moves well what we're here
to see the bullet time what we're here
to talk about today is kind of about
being neo it's about immersing yourself
in a computer-generated environment and
Palmer Luckey here was really one of the
first guys to make this work when he was
just a teenager Palmer created the first
prototypes of a device that we know now
as the oculus rift which is a really
groundbreaking virtual reality headset
now Palmer people have probably heard of
oculus and heard of the rift but maybe
some of them don't really know what it
is how it works the rift is an
affordable low latency high field of
view virtual reality headset designed
specifically for gaming I guess the way
that I usually tell old people when they
say what is the rift like my fight my
relatives I say well you you you know
how ski goggles work right you put them
on and you see the world outside right
you they're like yes and I say okay
imagine if you had ski goggles that you
could plug into a computer and then when
you looked around you saw the inside of
a videogame and usually after a few
rounds of going back and forth with this
analogy they kind of understand the
thing that I found with the rift is that
for a lot of people you can explain what
it is but it isn't really until people
try it on and run through the demos
where they have like that oh my god I
get at moment it's not just virtual
reality it's anything that people
haven't tried before like if if people
have a frame of reference to start from
like I have a smartphone oh I see it's a
better smartphone I understand why it's
better that's one thing with a
technology like virtual reality or like
the wearable wearables we're seeing you
really have to to try it to understand
why it would why why you'd want it to be
something you used regularly this isn't
just like a new kind of TV this is like
the invention of TV this is
a whole new paradigm with a different
way of interacting with with media yes
it's a disruptive paradigm shift right
there and I'm just I I I'd say that it's
more than just just a new screen because
it does allow you to do things you
wouldn't do on a traditional display
there's never been a display that could
reliably induce a sense of presence
which is the sense of being in a virtual
environment on a subconscious level
before now I mean they've existed but
certainly not at a consumer level price
point but the thing to remember is it
virtual reality as it exists today is
still pretty primitive compared to what
we want it to be the more exciting the
more exciting thing is where it's going
to go in the future because virtual
reality brought to its ultimate
conclusion isn't just a new form of
television or a new type of screen it's
an entirely new medium they can simulate
all of the past ones and standalone as
its own as its own set of experiences
well let's talk a little bit about that
experiences I mean we have a lot of
different people in this audience from
different industries and how might the
rift and other VR devices be used in
their industries main reason that games
are driving the rift right now and the
reason they'll continue to do so in the
future isn't that it's necessarily the
most exciting use in the long run it's
that right now the games industry is the
only industry with the tools and the
talent to create real-time immersive 3d
environments I view those talents do
exist in other industries but not on the
mass scale that you see in the games
industry but there's people using it for
a lot of other things one common use is
architectural pre-visualization so that
you can walk through a virtual home
before you actually have to build and
you're actually in the environment you
can look out the windows you can see oh
that's their case is off on their how
and that makes a big difference being
able to see things at the right scale
and depth is is really critical when
you're talking about something like
architecture and it's more than just
architecture people there are other
there are other scenarios where this is
really important like there's people
that are using it for for all kinds of
different training whether it's
emergency first responders or surgeons
or people that are learning to drive
cars how would the Rif maybe be used in
health care so the rift is not a medical
device and this thus not subject to FDA
regulation
and it's important that we keep that in
mind is we have this hypothetical
discussion but there's already some
people who are doing some interesting
experimental work with the rift where
they're actually trying to skin
operating rooms as operating as
operations are being done with multiple
cameras and so that they can then pipe
that into a 3d environment that can be
viewed on the rift so the idea is that
someone who wants to learn about some
particular like a medical med student
who wants to learn about some particular
surgery can watch a VR recording of
something that's done and they can pause
it they can zoom in they can zoom out
they can rewind and they can have a lot
more control over viewing the experience
and they would even if they were really
in the room with the surgeon themselves
VR has the potential to do some really
interesting things like that what about
an industry like fashion or retail yes
there's some stuff that's being worked
on so that you can fit virtual clothes
onto a onto a skin of your body to see
how they look and I think education is
also going to be a huge a huge is going
to benefit a lot from virtual reality
one thing that we've always seen value
and as society is like sending kids on
field trips actually sending them to do
things not just to read about it in a
textbook that's because most for most
people reading in a textbook is not the
most efficient way to learn something or
remember something the problem is that
right now the people who can do these
things are really geographically and
socioeconomically limited like I was I
just came here from Washington DC and I
was visiting the Smithsonian and I was
noting how all of the kids in the entire
DC area all get to visit the Smithsonian
you know all of its different museums as
kids but that's an experience that most
people across the country could not
realistically do and a lot of kids that
are in lower-income schools they they
could never dream of going to anything
remotely close to that virtual reality
is a technology that potentially enables
people to experience things in a way
that's similar to real life to get a lot
of that value and have a lot of the same
experiences and get them on this uneven
playing field so that it's not just the
elite few who get to come to cities like
DC or Philadelphia and learn about the
arts learn about
science so is this actually the kind of
thing where you know our kids or our
grandchildren will be sitting in their
classroom they'll pop on our rift and if
they're learning about World War two are
they going to find themselves on Omaha
Beach with bullets with whizzing past
their head why does there need to be a
classroom it's like back in the day if
you said in the future everyone is going
to have the ability to be in the same
room talking to different people on
their own telephone and they would have
said what are you gonna do you're gonna
have a telephone room and there's gonna
be 12 telephones just all over the walls
and everyone's just gonna be on the
phones up by the walls of course not it
turned out that we all just carry around
our own phones I think that that's a
more more likely model for how virtual
reality will be used it'll be a personal
device it likely crosses over with a lot
of augmented reality technology that
will not require going to a classroom to
use that kind of leads into a usage case
that probably touches all these
industries which is you know you get
this really immersive telepresence where
you know instead of just sitting on a
conference call where everyone's on
their speaker people are all you know
using the Rif to have their meetings
with each other that's interesting
beyond not just replacing conference
calls but I think more interesting is
replacing business meetings
I hate business meetings I hate
traveling for business meetings it would
be really interesting if virtual reality
could replace part or all of that travel
because it would let people have that
same level of human nuance without
wasting all of this money and time and
really a lot of our natural resources
just you know burning jet fuel all over
the world I've probably added a couple
couple degrees to the global temperature
myself so people who have tried out the
demo and I've used the rift get a lot of
these usage cases first hands and that
they find it very convincing
Mark Zuckerberg found it so convincing
that earlier this year he bought oculus
VR for a couple billion dollars you know
you were creating this device you were
inventing the rift you know kind of a
classical stereotype of like you know
putting this thing together as a hobby
in a garage but one of the things I
thought was interesting was it wasn't
just like you toiling away by yourself
it was a very collaborative effort where
you were participating in online forums
and working out a lot of the stuff with
other people as part of this VR
community what was that like and what
did you
get out of it this is an only true of
rotary out like the virtual reality
community that's true for every
community especially ones that are doing
new things that haven't been done in the
past if you wanted to talk to people
that had the same niche interest as you
you'd have to go for probably a couple
days a year to some niche convention
where you'd all you know hobnob about
whatever it is you're working on but now
you have people who are able to connect
from all over the world that never would
have met each other otherwise able to
work on these tough problems like
virtual reality and you see this over
and over again with innovation in the
hobbyist sector like whether it's lasers
or experimental ultra light aircraft or
indie video games or virtual reality
people collaborating on the Internet has
made a huge impact
so the riff definitely would not exist
if I wouldn't have had that ability to
connect with people to connect with
people online and it wasn't just like oh
that's pretty good but then the company
started you don't really need that a lot
of our early employees were actually
people that had that came out of out of
that community so once you had worked
out this prototype and you had something
you wanted to start showing to
developers need to raise money and you
know get the developers gets done and
you decided to do that through
Kickstarter to do a Kickstarter campaign
why kickstart something like this and
not just say I'm gonna get all my money
from VCS do you like free money who
doesn't what if I told you there was a
way you could raise free money without
giving away any equity right the reality
is actually a little more complicated
than that but that's the really easy
sell there were some traditional
investors and and other companies that
were interested in virtual reality and
it probably could have raised some money
but it would not have been the kind of
money that it wouldn't have been the
kind of money that we were looking for
at any kind of reasonable terms which
makes sense because virtual reality's
and entirely it at the time it was an
entirely unproven technology that had
never seen a single consumer success
Kickstarter was nice because all we we
didn't have to convince investors that
they would see a return on investment we
just had to convince the people who
actually wanted to use our device mostly
gamers and game developers that we would
give them something really cool so we
were able to sell directly to the people
who who believed in us and
wanted our product rather than going
through a middleman who is just looking
for a return on investment which i think
really really helped us you're not
promising return bellow and also we lost
money on the Kickstarter project overall
just to be clear so what yeah we we
grossly underestimated the amount of
time and money and resources it takes to
make thousands of something in a Chinese
factory yes we didn't make money in the
kickstarter units but what we got from
the kickstarter that was more valuable
than the money was the developer support
that we were really looking for and to
get it in the hands of as many people as
possible this was a way where we could
get a lot of developers using it at as
low of a cost as possible like our
long-term goal was let's say that we had
sold him for $1000 we might have been
able to make a couple million dollars
and we would have sold them to a lot
fewer people there'd be a lot fewer
people that have tried the rift that
we're building things for that we're
doing anything with it and you know that
doesn't translate into billions of
dollars of value it translates into a
couple million dollars but still win
Facebook bought the company there were
some of the Kickstarter backers who were
like what why aren't I getting any of
this Facebook money is that is that a
downside or potential hazard of
Kickstarter is that people are so
invested in the product I feel like
they're part of the company I think the
bigger risk that most people run in
backing a Kickstarter is that they never
get what they were promised which is
usually what happens I mean by the time
we got acquired by Facebook we had
shipped all of the Kickstarter units
more than a year prior so we definitely
delivered on all of our obligations I
like the idea of crowdsource of like of
crowdfunding and giving equity to people
but until I think it's part three of the
JOBS Act it goes through it's currently
illegal in the United States so you know
the man right okay and speaking of
the man after after the Kickstarter was
over you did go to the man some you did
get a lot of money from VCS and
traditional sources now you're an
engineer and you're also at the time
you're like 19 when you start talking to
be VCS and stuff do you have advice for
people who are going to go that route
and like try and get money from you know
you can get government grants but if
people are going to go to the more
traditional sources and ask
for like some guy or some system hand me
some money like what was your takeaway
from that so just to be clear the man
I'm talking about is the United States
federal government and the regulations
around the accredited investors not
necessarily a VC we're not saying
anything bad about your VC is that would
be clear about that
um few things to take away would be to
be honest I think it's it was great that
we had the Kickstarter to show VCS that
there was interest it's one thing to
pitch some VCS and say hey we've got
this great idea we've got this prototype
people are gonna love it it's another to
say look people actually already love it
and are saying good things I'm coming
from a position where I don't think I
could give the best advice on on how to
on how to attract VC money without that
publicity because I've never had to do
that we've always been in this luxurious
position of most species at least
knowing about us before we ever went
into the room which was super helpful I
do think that one thing that's important
is especially if you're a founder or a
technical founder is to realize that you
can't do everything and even if you can
you shouldn't even in my other projects
like when I was doing game console
modding and running this other website I
tried to surround myself with people and
staff members and and helpers who were
better than me and all the things I
couldn't do well and I think that VCS
are you know there's they're smart guys
they they can tell when someone has a
good idea and they can also tell when
maybe they are not the best person to
actually make it happen so if you're not
great at managing a business if you
don't think that it's something that
you're really passionate about that you
want to do you really should try to have
partners that they can do a good job if
I wouldn't have had those people on
board I think I would have had a much
harder time pitching my company because
it's like look we have this Kickstarter
we raised a bunch of money and I have no
idea what I'm doing now but you are
still a manager a lot of ways is there a
major takeaway from that like advice for
people about what maybe not to do if
you're the boss biggest thing is get
someone else to be the boss I mean I did
that really early on it's kind of
interesting because early on when the
company started and it was just well I
guess before the company
formerly started I was working on the
rift for years before the Kickstarter
but when it was just me it was just
myself and a garage tinkering whatever I
wanted to work on with no regard for
profitability or money or anything like
that and I was posting everything I was
doing online somebody could have taken
it at anytime and I actually would have
been happy if somebody had done that I
mean that was that was like living the
dream you know being in the garage doing
what you want to do and then when the
company started in earnest and we did
our Kickstarter it was me and like three
four other guys and all of a sudden I
have to do everything I'm not doing
engineering anymore I'm stuck doing
customer service I'm running to FedEx to
ship things I'm taking trips to China to
manage production and I'm not that good
at any of those things and it really
eats into what what you're doing and
that was that was really tough the good
news is that we kept hiring people who
are good at all these things so we got a
real logistics person we got a person
who could help us with recruiting we got
someone who could manage all of the
manufacturing in China and so as the
company got larger it actually got
easier to work go back to working on
well the bigger the company got the less
of a manager I needed to be and that was
that was really nice doing what you love
is a great note to end on everybody
please give us a cheap safe and of
applause for Palmer Luckey Thanks
you